you come in here moving and shaking man
you come in here making deals you're on
the phone already gotta do it you're
always moving I mean is there anything
else to do is there anything else to do
to get ahead no no especially not now
man
hunters hunt yes those that don't get
ate the last time you were here man that
was one of the most inspirational
podcasts I've ever done I left that I
literally had a shift and the way I was
looking at things like you put an extra
gear in my step that day I was like oh I
love being around people like you my guy
people around you you you people like
you you're you're going for [ __ ] all the
time
and it's infectious it's like you're you
you give off energy and with people
around you they want to they want to get
[ __ ] done to theirs contagious its
contagious that's not it's not just me
putting it out I think that uh the last
time I was here our conversation was
such a great conversation because there
was there was we both had point of views
right and when we shared the point of
views you elevated the other person's
POV like when we were talking and I was
telling you why I live the way I live
why I am the way I am you springboarded
then you said yeah because kept for me
I've been doing this and and we had this
big and yang thing going and it and it
drove the conversation I told you you
know before we jumped on one of the the
best interviews that I've ever done and
from a feedback perspective with people
that just loved what the discussion was
loved the tone of the interview two
things that was said felt inspired
motivated after it was just great all
around for me checked all the boxes it
was from me too and I got a bunch of
great responses from my friends from fro
that's when I know it's good when I get
friends and my friends were all like
pretty unanimous that is a motivational
[ __ ] Wow like that dude get [ __ ]
done when people hear stuff like you if
someone who's excited about life excited
about doing things you know there's
something about that that it's fuel it's
fuel for you we need that everyone needs
that you know I don't even this is this
is not a cheesy segue all right this
just makes sense from what you just said
what you just said is the reason why I
did the decision you said people need
that it's fuel yeah right I feel that in
today's time what people are most
selfish with this information nobody
wants to give information you got to ask
for it if you ask for it then I maybe
maybe I'll tell you some stuff but it's
a search and find I mean real good real
information information about how to get
to success that's the that's the one
from everybody across the board on some
level right okay everybody's success is
different
this doesn't mean Fame and in stars I'm
not talking about that level of success
for everything I'm saying whatever your
version of success is to get to it
information from someone that's done it
or that's part taken in it and some
degree will only add to the value of
your journey it's only gonna make it
easier it's not to say that you got to
do what they said but be with that
information you're able to process it
maybe use it maybe not right but you got
it right that's what I wanted to do I
say yo I got it I got a [ __ ] I got a
life I got a hell of a life that I've
lived full of ups downs potholes
cobblestone speed bumps flat road
u-turns some smack brick walls that I
ran into you know some revolving doors
of back and forth and through it all my
mental has only gotten better because I
feel like I've been in I've been in a
mental gym the mental fitness that that
coincides with life you know it should
get better it [ __ ] you should get wiser
you should get smarter you should be
able to make better decisions and all of
my decisions came from the massive
amount of fuck-ups and I can now share
those fuck-ups
I can now share the rights and the
wrongs and the way that I handle all of
the things that I've done and people can
just take that information and go wow I
never looked at it like that will give
some better view of the landscape yeah
especially when someone like you you you
almost seem like an unattainable person
like how how does he do that how is he
doing that how does this guy go from
Philadelphia to beat one of the biggest
movie stars in the world
how does he become one of the biggest
stand-up comedy stars ever how the [ __ ]
do you do that you almost seem like an
alien you know to people on the outside
but then when they hear you talk about
your real life and talk about these
fuck-ups talk about these successes and
talk about the lessons that you've
learned man that's fuel for folks in a
way that nothing else is because it's
there's a lot of people that are
bullshitting online there's a lot of
these motivational speakers that haven't
done [ __ ] and it's a it's a weird thing
it's like they're they're trying to give
you motivation by like sort of reciting
things that they think are gonna work
they think that they think we want to
hear someone has done something when you
say it people are gonna listen they're
gonna go oh and you're so honest about
everything which is every that's
everything to people because when you're
pure when you're your words are pure
people take them right in they come
right in there's no there's no like
house guys kind of [ __ ] selling me
something I was gonna sell [ __ ] yeah I
got nothing to sell I had a I had a talk
with chase like chase JP Morgan Chase
and partners of mine and we were doing
this we're not we were we are we don't
think all advanced and black pathways
right we're trying to cure financial
literacy in the black community
we've been we're on like year number two
right now right and there was a
conversation where you know they wanted
to have said bankers go and talk to the
kids in the inner city and I was like
you can't you can't send a white man
that works for JPMorgan Chase to the
inner city of sad community hood
whatever to talk to these young black
kids that has no idea about the life
that the black kids living I said what
you need is people that have actually
come from these environments they have
made it out of the environments and now
understand how money works because now
when I talk to you I'm not talking to
you with hypotheticals and I'm not
preaching to you about what you should
do and what you gotta do
I said I'm telling you what I did that
didn't work I'm telling you I've [ __ ]
off money and I'm telling you what I
didn't know hey guys here's a fact there
is no education that comes with money in
the black communities it doesn't you can
go search for it there isn't one it does
not exist there is no one that is
outright teaching the kids in a black
community how to operate financially how
to set up for your future there is
nobody talking to you about ownership
homes mortgages investments stocks but
that doesn't exist it doesn't exist it's
not until you get out of that
environment that you meet some people
that are planning their life accordingly
that you start to ask questions it's not
so maybe college and on the later side
of it that you're with people that are
getting jobs in the future that you
start to do it there is no prep or
education at a young age I said so you
need you need a [ __ ] man that can go
there and go amen let me tell you why
y'all gotta stop taking these free
credit cards let me tell you why you got
to stop putting the cable in somebody
else's name and continuing to [ __ ] it up
let me tell you why you got to stop
being okay we're not having a bank
account let me tell you why you gotta
stop using the check cashing places
there's nobody giving that information
mmm I said that's what I am so if we're
gonna have a relationship let's build it
all for something I'll thinning let's
build it all for something that people
can go I get that
since then to go back to your point my
relationship has been based on me
telling the truth I told JPMorgan Chase
I want to go to the inner city and I
want to have these discussions but let
me have them my way I don't want to have
it in a JP Morgan Chase way and I gotta
credit them for backing me because they
align me with other people that shared
the same stories that have achieved
certain levels of success that speak to
the same thing so everything that I've
done everything that I'm trying to do
when I do talk about it I come proving
I'm only talking about this because I
really got knowledge about it
I don't got knowledge about it because
I'm smartest [ __ ] word that's
not what a knowledge is coming from Joe
my knowledge is coming from a man yo
don't walk the door number one
hasn't one stirring yet there's a bunch
of [ __ ] in that door it wasn't till I
came out that door that I saw those
monsters that I knew the other monsters
weren't as bad in door number two but
door number three is finally where you
should go I messed up man I went to the
first two doors wrong why can't I give
that to somebody that that hasn't
experienced those doors yet why can I
just get that information and possibly
prevent them from walking into those
doors and that's what's really valuable
for people listening is what's really
valuable someone has actually done it
and done it wrong and done it right and
like hey listen I [ __ ] up this is how
I [ __ ] up that that means so much to
people really that you're you're
advancing people's possibilities it's I
think that's what life should be about
yeah as as adults as adults we have a
job to do whether you want to admit the
night your job is to set up the next
generation that's our job whether you
want to [ __ ] admit it or not it's
your kids it's your friends it's
whomever you're supposed to live a
certain way do certain things to set up
for the next generation to come and to
be able to do better if you don't then
you're not doing your part and if the
world never [ __ ] grows you got to
raise your hand and be responsible hmm
cuz you're part of the leg yeah you're
part of the delay if we look up in 15 20
years and we're in the same spot what
that means that our [ __ ] ground
breakers that was doing all the [ __ ]
during that 15 20 years never shared the
information so that these new people
come through a break new ground yeah
somebody got to do more than what the
[ __ ] I did I don't care what is right
but you got to do more right somebody
gotta [ __ ] do more somebody got to
break these records in you already
believes the trail yeah this dude
all I did was show you amen hey they
stopped here but I kept going to left
and I start haul ass and look what I
found now that I'm over here that means
it's more did you have a time in your
life where you realize that you were
doing the right thing like a
time of your life where you realized
like in your comedy career in particular
well you realize like I'm getting some
[ __ ] traction I'm like this is really
rolling like in the beginning you
probably like all of us were not sure
what was gonna happen you're trying you
know you doing open mics trying to make
it who but was there a time were you
like this approach is this is happening
I got traction it was when I think I
think the the noticing of oh [ __ ] of
something's happening right now and it's
it's this is I think this is a success I
think I think I'm I think I'm in it was
it around the time your first special
look wasn't it was when I did the Shaq
all-star coming just I just told
somebody this story I was talking to
Gary Owens actually good friend of mine
comedian and we were talking about the
pass and you know Gary was like keV
there was a moment where you just
[ __ ] just just ran past everyone and
he was like I don't remember exactly
what it was that did it
he said I just remember looking up and
you were gone and I remember it was the
Shaq all-star Comedy Jam the lineup was
Saturday entertainer he was hosting it
was DeRay Davis Tommy Davidson and
myself it's a hell of a lineup
it was DeRay Davis and Tommy Davidson
myself Saturday entertainer was the host
and I closed out the show and I remember
going to do two shows in Phoenix it was
in around and I had to do this is when I
was about to tape seriously funny my
next special at the girl little man so
seriously funny I was taping like four
months it was already on the books so
this is this is supposed to be it this
is my big coming-out party this has to
be it man you know I feel like I'm ready
I've been working hard my jokes are
hidden I'm wrong I'm edgy this is it
this is the one I'm [ __ ] funny
seriously that's why I titled it
seriously funny I was I was I was ready
I get the call from Jeff Hannigan Shaq's
all-star Comedy Jam we're taping at keV
do it's like 15 20 minutes you know can
you do it for me and Jeff and I had a
relationship
and I was a gentleman table especially I
want to burn that material he's like keV
look you can use some other stuff 15-20
minutes we tape it but you know these
things get some good traction good views
is some good eye candy you should just
have it out there all right whatever
I wasn't even taking a serious this is
not something that was saying serious
and this is an example of sometimes you
don't know what it's going to be you
don't know what the fuel and the rocket
is going to be mmm
you just got a [ __ ] buckle up and be
prepared for the takeoff now if it
takeoff and you don't know where the
seat belts are and you don't know where
the lights and [ __ ] at well now you got
a [ __ ] up rocket ride you going you on
crash it's over it's over if you're not
ready yeah I do it this thing airs and I
remember watching it and at the end of
the show something so small seems so
[ __ ] big I say good night I put up
two fingers and as I'm walking off the
stage they put it in slow motion they
put me in slow motion walking off the
stage and it was a separation from
everything else that was on there it was
almost like this guy's the the guy it
was it was a it was a small tweaking
editing I had nothing to do with it I
just saw it and the slow-motion walk off
the crowd getting up clapping you see
people's faces slow-motion point in
screaming and I'm walking off with like
a bob and it was almost like a coined
this is it this is going to be the guy I
didn't do it I didn't mean for it to
happen I didn't know what was gonna
happen
god bless the editors god bless the Shaq
all-star Comedy Jam
after that aired I remember doing a show
at Caroline Jones is a true [ __ ]
story shout out to Lewis from Caroline's
comedy club I was just doing a weekend
weekend you supposed to be doing you
know three shows we set off 15 shows
so how 15 listen we was there for like
eight days we're never like 8 days you
can Louis can confirm this Caroline's
comedy club that's crazy
Michael Berkowitz can't confirm this
that's my public of parents agent we
just kept getting calls it were gone we
just put the tickets up for another show
they're gone what Oh what do you want to
do we can add another you want to try to
do a a Wednesday night yeah go ahead
it's gone Kevin we added the Wednesday
it's gone what do you want to do you
want to see if we can add a a Late Show
Wednesday yeah [ __ ] it I guess it's gone
Tuesday went Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday Monday
Tuesday we've been that [ __ ] till God
there Wednesday holy Sh 15 shows
Caroline's comedy club would that feel
like when it was I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say 12 to 15 shows I remember because
some of the things we could do one some
we could do two but you don't know I'm
like I can't I can't even understand
this Caroline's comedy club is a big
comedy club this is New York City this
is the this is the melting pot where you
got some of everybody after that is when
me and Burt said is this a New York
thing is that the word get out in New
York and we found out the Shaq's
all-star Comedy Jam was playing on like
Showtime around the clock it was just
being pumped all day all night and we
put up some shows outside and the comedy
club start firing who's adding shows we
said let's do small theaters and then I
did small theaters in right after that
moment I taped seriously funny
so Shaq's all-star Comedy Jam hit so
hard that by the time I was ready to do
seriously funny which was in three to
four months people were so hype and
ready to see me do something else that
that became a massive attraction Wow
seriously funny took off and blew as
well that's crazy that it was something
that you weren't even really thinking
not even thinking about it maybe that's
why I was so free you know for sure yeah
the [ __ ] there's nothing up by the way
seriously funny I damn this [ __ ] myself
in Photoshop I damn defecated on myself
before the show because I'm like man
these people are here
the theaters sold out so fast I had
LeBron Shaq the the whole Cleveland
Cavalier team was there at the time it
was unreal I was like this is this is it
this is my moment I gotta I gotta make
this I gotta make this a thing Wow I got
it man I can't [ __ ] this up
I cannot [ __ ] this up the show ended up
going great and then from there the the
the [ __ ] star just continued to rise
and and that's when the engine within
myself started the click of go get right
so there's something you always had the
go get I got always had that I always
had that I talked before that's my mom
all right P Nancy Hart don't tell me I
can't do something good now I'm pissed
now I'm gonna do it don't tell me that
and that's a gift and a curse yes that's
a gift and a curse like you saw in the
dark I love you saw bird in my
documentary I put it all out there
that's a curse cast don't put that video
up don't do that don't tell me what the
[ __ ] not to do I'm gonna do it and
sometimes they don't do what you think
it was gonna do you don't know
everything you don't know everything and
you're not that great to think that you
do know everything and you can get bit
in the ass by thinking that but you got
to get bit to go oh let me get better at
that yes so my go get comes from me just
saying what's my reason not to go after
everything that I possibly can
I will stand on a [ __ ] building and
say this man it's a game this this thing
is serious but it's got a game-like
quality to it this thing called life
mmm it's got a game-like quality to it
and if you don't [ __ ] see that you
gotta open your eyes you want to open
your [ __ ] eyes because in this life
the moves that we're making allow you to
do more to to get more
to see more travel more explore
experience or some people or dealt a
different hand and it's tougher it's a
darker road and it's dammit it's [ __ ]
I'm I want to get out of this I can't
I'm doing uh how do I get out but I made
it oh it looked like I wasn't supposed
to get out but I'm out everybody said
you can't get out of this [ __ ] I did
about I'm out I'm one of the people that
got out and it's a [ __ ] it's got a
real game like quality to it and that
doesn't mean that you play with it
understand what I'm saying here it means
that you can do what you put your mind
to and if you continue to put your mind
to it the game opens up new levels tell
me I'm [ __ ] saying something wrong
you're saying something right you get a
new level in each new level that gets
opened up you're able to adapt a
different mindset and a different
approach you can stop at that level or
you can go I want more levels I want
more [ __ ] levels I don't like seeing
[ __ ] that I have no idea how to obtain
or gain access to that frustrates me
that frustrates me when people do things
and I don't know how they do it or did
it what I'm gonna do it and I want to
know when when you're around people that
work in different atmospheres what do
you do man oh man I'm the guy that takes
these labels right here several labels
right here I have a manufacturing
company company where I do these but I
do them in bulk so we do a thousand
labels every 30 seconds and I built a
manufacturing lab and this company here
pays me X on a dollar and I got 35
companies doing the same thing I've
built a multi-million dollar business
based off labels people don't understand
how important labels are I did at the
young age so I started manufacturing
labels you can manufacture [ __ ]
labels now I'm now I'm intrigued even if
I didn't want to do that I'm intrigued
that that's a thing I'm intrigued I'm
tree that you found a way to do that
this table is a handmade there's a
company do these is it [ __ ] custom
where's the wood from if you really dig
into everything it comes from a fault it
comes from a broken down thought so you
can be a person that's just around a
bunch of brilliant thoughts never ask
questions or you can soak some of that
[ __ ] up you know this pandemic showed me
Joe how our economy really [ __ ] works
once again I'm coming from the
perspective of a young black man from
the hood
I'm from the bottom I don't know [ __ ]
about stocks I don't know nothing about
investments never have right but I know
through this pandemic now that I'm at a
point where I'm actually into stocks and
I'm investing and putting a portfolio
together well I really looked at the way
that the world moves I really looked at
how we move his people how are we
[ __ ] still going what are we using
what are we [ __ ] using this is what I
said to my kids I said what are you
still using what do you mean on a day to
day what do we have to use tell me
things we have to use toothpaste who
makes the toothpaste they told me who
made the toothpaste is that a company
that you can invest in do you feel like
everybody uses this toothpaste if you do
that means that this is a company that's
been successful it may be successful for
a long time because there's a necessary
need of everyone that's an investment
kids what else do we use what else do we
use every day what do you go what do you
like in the morning Starbucks is that an
investment do you feel like everybody
drink Starbucks we drank it all the time
you feel like everybody else does too I
think so that's an investment that's
what you put money in because you feel
like it's going to last is going to grow
what stores do we go to where are we
always at Target
how many people would target when we go
a lot is that an investment I guess why
do you guess at this point you should
know we talked about a long time why do
you think it's an investment there why
do you think it's not I'm talking to you
about putting my
in places where you feel like it's going
to grow do you feel like targets are
going to shut down tomorrow or do you
feel like they're gonna open more stores
how do you feel this is a thing that I
watch and this is a thing that I also
watch people ignore this is what it's
wrong with our world because we don't
talk to people enough like this we don't
give them a simplicity behind the way we
[ __ ] move and the way the world goes
around if we did get the simplicity then
we could have people taking $20 out
their check and creating a portfolio we
can have people taking forty to fifty
dollars out their check and putting in a
same thing said stock said whatever it
is you can be doing it at a younger age
you don't have to have the most crazy
amount of money it can start off with
the smallest amounts of money but you
can learn it that can grow I watch it I
pay attention that's what gets me
[ __ ] coin Joe I pay attention to
everything my question is why don't most
of us why are we comfortable with
letting the world just go by I think a
lot of people don't have the framework
they don't know how to operate in that
realm they don't know how to get going
they don't know how to get started yeah
but I love what you said about it being
there's a game-like quality to life
that's such a perfect way to look at it
really is you played a game yeah you
played the game for how many years Joe
how many years the any podcast 11 11
years right I'm gonna give you a very
true story and to my brothers the
plastic cup boys we got our radio show
straight from the heart I'm constantly
preaching to us about it's not about now
it's about tomorrow our radio shows a
good radio show and we have a following
but it's not about now it's about
tomorrow we gotta put the work in today
so that when tomorrow comes we are well
equipped for the conversation that may
be I said Joe had a [ __ ] long ride
of preparing for tomorrow and when
tomorrow hit it had to hit correctly
because Joe never not did the work on a
day-to-day basis to prepare for tomorrow
I got everybody fired up just off of the
fact that you continue to do your thing
the way that you were regardless of
conversations regardless of other offers
and possibilities you felt something
else was on the horizon for tomorrow but
you knew it would come based off of your
energy and effort that you put into the
thing that you have realistically I
don't look at it that way how do you
look at it I don't I never look at a
destination or a thing or something
happening I just keep doing it I'm one
of those weird grinders it's not weird
but that's a way for you to go but I
trust the process but I don't never look
at it like there's a destination like a
success moment like a big thing a big
thing hits I just keep doing it and
those things sort of find their own way
through management and agents and I've
put very little thinking into that but
almost all my thinking in there just
doing the thing the best way that I can
do it metaphor you did you're an amazing
[ __ ] fighter you are I mean I don't
know how many black belts you [ __ ]
guys I just know I wouldn't [ __ ] with
you you but you got some [ __ ] with you
right and if you are practicing a kick
or a move if you do it
let's say 200 thousand times to make
sure you get it perfect are you doing
that and figuring it out for the unknown
or is it for if I ever have to use it I
wanted to be so [ __ ] right yeah
that's always there that's always there
but the thing is always the technique
the thing is always the process I think
that's where I got this from podcasting
and even from stand-up it's just the
grind the process comes from martial
arts the grind is like you got to be
there every day if you're there three
days a week it's not as good as five you
got to be there five days and five might
be better than seven because sometimes
seven you burn out you want to keep
enthusiasm because that's a fuel
enthusiasm there's something about
enthusiasm that like you got a balance
discipline and enthusiasm discipline is
critical you have to be able to show up
but you also have to enjoy the [ __ ] out
of it and so enjoying the [ __ ] out of it
with discipline is the key but you got
to ride those babies out you know you
don't want to [ __ ] every day take a
couple days want it you know like people
[ __ ] every day you don't need to know
what [ __ ] feels like take three or
four days off and smoke a joint make out
with your woman
do you feel like and this is something
that you know I never have a good
I've have an okay answer but I don't
feel like it's ever the best answer when
people say well what do you do when
you're not doing what you love right
and what I've said in in the past and
you know and the present as well is I
think in order to do what you love you
got to get through the obstacles of the
things that you don't love in life right
trying to come up yeah do you do you
agree with that like getting over those
hurdles and then eventually they lead
you to the thing where you're like okay
yeah now I'm ready to first pursue said
thing that I want to do or if you're in
a job or you know a career you're like I
[ __ ] hate my job what I feels like
you know even if you hate your job you
you're supposed to be using that job for
something to get to something right and
if you're if you're not then that should
be the thing that you're figuring out
like I don't like being here but now
that I'm here I'm going to do all that I
can to get said thing so that I can then
be comfortable enough to move here yeah
if you just go into those things with
hate cuz you were talking about
enthusiasms made me think we thought
maybe think about it if you just got
hate and you're just angry about what
you're doing every day then you're not
even allowing yourself to figure out the
plan of how to escape the thing that you
hate to get to the thing that you love
yeah I think it's important to have
those jobs it's sock man they're there
of their they like cement your
foundation live
you don't want to go back to those
[ __ ] places you don't want to go back
to those terrible jobs we got to get up
and be uninspired all day long but if
you can get through that like that
that's the this rigid structure of
discipline that allows you to apply that
discipline the things you love if you
can apply discipline and learn how to
apply it to something that sucks and get
free have a game plan to get free once
you get free you have that ability to
get up and do things that suck guess
what you're gonna get up and do things
you love even more
are you gonna remember construction
sites and delivering newspapers and all
the stupid jobs and I worked I think
about those [ __ ] things and I get up
in the morning I they when I'm brushing
my teeth I think about them that's the
[ __ ] game that's the game you gotta
get through it you have to like that
it's it's I I say this man and it's like
that it's the story you're just putting
that story together and I don't I don't
think you know with without without the
stories what do you talk about will you
talk about right you know what is what
is the interesting side of conference
conversation about your growth or your
journey if it's if it's if it's just the
easiest I just took the highway and got
over the exit and right there the exit I
found the gold everybody else did it
snow right my dad was rich and I have a
trust fund and I never have to work
every what what is that what is the
interesting side to that like I don't
there's no there is no bonus in that
like yeah I just [ __ ] broke my
goddamn back right the the dopest thing
for me about doing that was not being
able to walk but then being told that if
I'm patient I can recover fully I can
get back to myself in me instantly
thinking in my head I can actually be
better than what I was if he's telling
me I can get back 200 be better so the
game instantly clicked on all right
tomorrow we start we play new level I
can't [ __ ] walk goddamn here we go
can't wipe my ass I'm not [ __ ]
getting they say I can't get in the gym
Petey is some weird [ __ ] I'm just taking
two steps on the [ __ ] boots a ball
and I'm alright this is a little
discouraging but I know they said I'm
supposed to do it three days I'm gonna
listen to him but I don't knows other
all those other four days is there
anything else that I can do to be
working on Kevin your strengthen your
lungs up working with your breathing
here's a breathing machine okay what
about my my hands is there any way
my sense is tennis ball can I be
squeezing the shot doing anything no we
don't have anything like that we don't
recommend it so if I found something in
our research if it's just motor skills
and working on is that fine yeah that's
fine
but you know we it's it's it's okay if
that's what you want to do okay I saw
that yeah I'm not getting the same the
doctors are just telling me the stuff
that I need to know stay within those
lines I'm gonna find out things that I
can do because I'm playing a game now
I'm never gonna overexert myself but the
game is to be better how do I be better
than what I was because if I do that
oh [ __ ] for me mmm I'll just beat me
yeah they're saying about nobody else I
don't get [ __ ] about nobody else I just
beat me if I can keep beating myself
pulse if I can keep doing that then that
means that I'm in a battle with the only
person that [ __ ] makes sense I'm in a
battle with the only person that I
really wanna [ __ ] beat and that's me
I know I don't care about anybody else
I have no worry or gripe about the next
man a woman's journey or or or or their
level of success that's not what I'm
when I'm up against yeah if I can
continue to outdo me from the day before
then I'm then I'm ahead and I'm ahead
and that's that's what I that's the
newfound the newfound energy that I got
out of life now you know I'm on this
amazing rocky story what my self is in
my head nobody else is watching his
movie but me it's in my head this is
rocky this is the comeback this is
exactly what I saw moving I'm gonna come
back better than ever I'm gonna be 41 my
body's gonna be ripped
up on my being about 8% body fat and
then and then I'm ready ready for what
Kevin mmm [ __ ] enough I don't know
but that's that's what I want I want
that day to be like yeah yeah now what
and then I figure out what I figure out
what that what is then yeah tell me when
you got injured what what you you were
explaining to me before the podcast but
I want to talk too much about it because
I wanted to hear it
now so everybody could hear it what what
exactly was the injury iife' raptured
so I fractured my my spine right and
it's from my it's either from my t10 to
my l1 for my l1 to my teat in whatever
order that goes in
so I how many fractures I mean that's
[ __ ] that sure that's just fine
that's about so you fractured basically
everything everything I mean you got
like this much space in my back so you
got to think first of all I'm already
small all right so this is practically
my whole back if you look at this right
here
this is practically normal back so all
of this fractured and what what happens
is they had to fuse my spine so they
have to remove the discs in between they
basically had to fix so so the bones
where it's fractured basically your
spine is now out of whack the the the
things that keep your spine connected
and that allows you the flexibility are
out of whack I got pieces of those bone
fragments that are out of place out so
so they got a they got a fuse that [ __ ]
back together so I got the disc material
out and compress it and then screw them
also is the bone or one piece now I I
think I'm I think I'm one I don't I
don't know about the disc I don't know I
don't have that answer that's uh that's
a little too technical for me and I
should know that because it was my body
but what I do know is that this thing
that's my spine has eight screws and
these eight screws now hold it together
so through this time of healing because
I now have metal in my back it was about
getting your back to be comfortable with
the metal
but also back to a normal level of
flexibility so where people [ __ ] up when
you get this type of energy and you stay
still you allow that metal to get stiff
you don't you don't you're not moving it
so so now your movements become robotic
with it so because as soon as I got out
the hospital I started I didn't have
days off as soon as I got out I started
physical therapy I did not wait I didn't
I got off medication I said I'm not
taking on meds you know my dad was on
drugs I was like I'm not [ __ ] around
with that so I dealt with the pain but I
got to start now because every day that
I wait makes it harder to go so because
I was you know back and forth side to
side doing all of those things I got I
got my body to get accustomed to it and
I got flexibility so now we used to be
working out it looks as if I'm back and
you know I'm probably 98% back to myself
right now but the work that I put into
my core and my upper body over the years
are what saved me outside of God of
course in that situation because you
know I want to tell us people just for
just for you to know this health and
wellness [ __ ] is so much bigger than
what you may think it is taking care of
your body you don't know when all that
stuff comes into play and adds up
correctly you know the the human body is
amazing recovery the ability to snap
back and go back to what it once was the
body muscle memory all that stuff plays
a major factor so my healing was a lot
faster because of the years of work that
I put into him before now if I had
enough and I didn't have that court well
I'll be paralyzed I'll be [ __ ]
paralyzed I mean they set up you're
literally talking about this much doctor
looked me in the eyes you're lucky to be
walking here this much if your core
wasn't in the shape that it was and if
you didn't have the the strength to take
what
ever that impact wasn't stay you would
have been snapped and you would never be
walking again so that instantly thank
God I go you know what thank God for my
trainer who jumped into my life at a
certain time and changed my way of
thinking boss
Ronald balls ever lying and you know
we've been rocking for seven years and
and the consistency of four years before
of every day every day so now I'm like
you you're not wasting your time ever so
when those people say what are you
working out for what are you getting the
shape for why going everyday you don't
know when you're gonna need to [ __ ]
tap into all it'll work that you've done
you don't know you don't know if you
ever need it but to just know that
you've taken care of yourself to know
that you've given yourself a chance to
[ __ ] not only survive but perform
you've given yourself a chance to
perform at a high level in a day to day
by taking care of your engine this is
this is my machine so I'm taking care of
the engine just like any car oil changes
just like you know your [ __ ] your
brakes your tires the rotors all that
[ __ ] you taking care of that so it's a
great ride every time you got to do the
same with your body don't ignore that
[ __ ] people you know we dropping like
flies right now mmm heart attack strokes
yeah you know you get kidney failure you
got people with diabetes you got people
getting legs arms cut off from bad
eating from from bad eating over the
course of years take that [ __ ] serious
don't wait to the end that's serious
that's not that's not a joke so when I
look at people dying around me we have
no control over when a day is gonna come
but I'm going to try to help amplify my
time here as much as I can that's the
big one right amplify your time you have
energy get different kind of energy than
someone was unhealthy you have the
ability to push forward you have the
ability to get you then you have more
enthusiasm
because your body feels good why are you
not why I want to be careful what I say
this because I don't want to seem like
I'm coming down on anybody that's not
but why don't you want to take care of
yourself I think they do I think it's
just habits are very hard to break
there's a lot of comfort in just the
same thing every day open up the cabinet
Twinkies [ __ ] it I'll start tomorrow
[ __ ] it I feel like eating those chips
just settle into it and then there's
this disappointment that comes from
settling in and it's comfort in its
disappointment at the same time like you
really well I guess that's me and you
accept it and I think sometimes people
are scared of improvement because
they're scared of failure so if they can
just kind of slide into the same
[ __ ] every day
it makes them feel less less uneasy you
know what I what I say and and what I
will say goes back to the decision goes
back to information it's not bad if you
want those things I don't I don't think
that people are supposed to live a
robotic life in and you know I don't eat
this ever and I don't do this well
there's more to the rock and his [ __ ]
cheat days I mean it's she's he eats for
a village that son of a [ __ ] it's
unreal what he puts down when he puts
down that's what I'm saying like you
should enjoy your your yourself and
enjoy your life but I think that there
should be a give-and-take like all right
I'm gonna eat the way I want to eat I'm
not compromising that because I love
food but let me put a half hour in a day
of walking let me yeah let me do
something so where I'm active so there's
at least a give-and-take that's what I
would say to people out there I'm not
saying in no way shape or form don't do
this ever and that's wrong and you live
in you're gonna destroy yourself that's
no that's unrealistic that's unrealistic
yeah I think you should definitely be
happy you should definitely do the
things that you enjoy because like I
said in my mind this is a game you
playing the game you'd be happy while
you're playing the more miserable one
way to play the game is to challenge
yourself like give yourself a month
write down for a month for one month I'm
not drinking a single soda for one month
I'm gonna do something some exercise
every day and I'm gonna write down what
it is for one month the [ __ ] game
yeah
here's how I think I don't know if
that's a book title or not or if it
hasn't has been a hasn't but goddamn it
that could be my next one the game yeah
humans I think it may be but maybe you
know the game the game of life
that's something but it's something
there I just know there's there's it's
such a synergy within that maybe just
call it game something yeah it's there's
your statement of there's a game like
quality to life resonates it's just as
soon as you said that I was like ooh
that's it that's the way to look at it
don't just look at it like life look at
it like you're trying to succeed you're
trying to get ahead and win the game
like quality of life that's it it's it's
it's it's a it's adult thing I'm gonna
want to really harp on it so you know
you're recovering from your your back
injury look how long ago was the injury
how long ago was the crash now September
so what is that September October
November December January February March
April was his May yeah so me only eight
months almost as bad we June's about to
be nine I'm gonna get in tonight and you
said 98% I'm down to probably 10% body
fat right now and as far as like
movement you could basically do
everything I'm doing everything
Wow doing everything I'm up to running
again I'm probably at I'm probably a
three I can go three and a half miles
straight before I'm like oh the back
starts to bother ya before I get tight
and what are you doing for the back you
doing yoga are you doing what kind of I
got a physical therapy you know that's
that's random shout-out to dr. Pat you
know I make sure that getting two
massages getting a work done because I'm
doing so much within working out I don't
want to not take care of that as well so
from heating it from you know treatment
just just literally doing things to to
make sure that I'm I'm constantly
working on those muscles and not
forgetting them I'm getting older I
don't want to act like that's not the
case or that's not a reality I'm 40 now
so how do I take care of this machine so
at 50
I'm not moving as if I'm 70 right now I
would say that's been that's been a
great adjustment but one that's really
made me feel better like stretching you
know I didn't I didn't understand the
importance of stretching of actually
resting you know I was gotta get it
let's go let's go Tom Waits
hit it clanging and banging baby
clanking and banging but now you know
make sure you get your rest time so that
you can come back and give the energy
your cardio changes role machines come
on I'm on a bike you know I'm I'm
peloton and I'm hydro and I'm running so
the workouts change and you become more
consistent with your system with my new
system so I think by July July my goal
is for my 41st birthday that July 6 to
be around eight eight and a half percent
body fat at the age 41 so it's all about
it's all about looking good with the
body fat for me for me the body fat
means that I've just been super focused
mmm like no I eat I don't people to
think that I don't eat I'm I'm not a
foodie though so it doesn't really count
but you know I'm not owing some strict
crazy diet I don't you know the food
alert you don't enjoy like I'm not a
foodie man I don't know I don't eat red
meat I really know red meat no no fish
no seafood I'm a plant base eater
everything everything's plant
I'll go chicken every once in a while
I'll dab alit to my chicken that's what
other people don't understand I don't
think people really get that or
understand that it's like just because
you make the decision to go and try
plant-based doesn't mean that you have
to engulf in that world learn it
understand it and see if there's
benefits that work for you I stopped
eating red meat so much because I
learned that I didn't have to have it I
thought that I needed it to survive
that's what I was under the mindset like
if I don't eat this I'm things are gonna
change for me that's what I thought but
once I found out there was protein and
things
in other foods and other resources and
then I started to learn more about the
plant-based food space I was like i'ma
give it a try and I started trying to be
I meet and I [ __ ] fell in love with
behind me know that I don't feel the
difference let me tell you something
right now those beyond meat things are
not good for you I love them I'm sure
you do I'm sure you enjoy that's fine I
like if you're gonna be plant-based
that's not the way to go in terms of
like the overall health it's not bad if
you want just taste if you enjoy you
know just mouth pleasure but they're not
good for you
I saw oils it's all this plant-based
oils and it's all processed and weird
just eat vegetables what you are is a
very smart man so I would never
challenge the information that you may
have that I don't have so now after
being told such a thing I would look and
see for myself but I can say to date
I love the beyond option because it's
not only taking the place of the meat I
like the different versions of it that's
available as long as you're enjoying it
and wrong like something you enjoy and
you're obviously very healthy yeah I
could say I I haven't seen I put it this
way since since going plant-based and
jumping into that space and choosing
that because there was a moment where
you have the impossible you had the
beyond and you had all the stuff that
was out there and you're trying
everything I like that one the most
so after liking the beyond one the most
then I said let me see if I can be more
consistent since doing that I've I've
seen a significant change and just being
more vibrant more up and at it like you
know my days were always long so there
used to be a wall that I would hit you
know when I was eating and I was red
meat whether it be the burger patty
without the bun whether it was steak and
eggs for protein whatever was I would
always hit a wall a day where you know
I'm dozing I'm dozing and I'm crashing I
don't have those crashes if you weren't
getting enough carbohydrates could be
once again Joe you have very smart
minutes I'm not gonna
your knowledge because I've noted this
is a space where you're well-equipped
you do your research you read you know
I've heard you talk about things various
times in this space I'll just say it's
is one of those things where I was like
okay this is a pattern that I fell into
it's been comfortable but I've seen the
results that's all that matters in this
bio available bio variability that
everybody has to take any consideration
like your body's gonna be different than
Jamie's is gonna be different than mine
everybody's body's gonna respond
different to different kind of foods it
really it's really different you know
some people or work great off of just
fish I know people that are on a
carnivore diet and then the healthiest
shape they've ever been in their life
all they eat is red meat these rib eyes
all day long and you go what the [ __ ]
anyone that looks great and they'll
swear to you they've never felt better
psoriasis is gone joint pain gone
healthier than ever and then I know
other people that are all 100%
plant-based know like I got off my meds
I feel great I think focus on eating
properly whether it's eating properly
plant-based or eating properly with a
carnivore died just cutting out all the
[ __ ] yeah that's the in it and
focusing on the fact that you're eating
for health and for vitality like that's
a big part of it you just said the key
thing no the the key things you just
said is people are doing different
things that work for them yeah there
there is no right or wrong way and I
think that's the biggest misconception
right the misconception is that you're
doing it wrong one way there's only what
nah don't do that
don't eat that there's so many different
ways that can work for you don't be
afraid to try or just experience what
those options are and find your comfort
space like that's that's why I say
within that plant-based space you know
people that go get man on plant-based
but I feel bad cuz I ate seven thing
it's like you don't have like it's not
there is no rule you know to what you
want to do for you and you gotta be open
to making adjustments to do you know Ct
Fletcher I do know of him I don't know
him but I know of him loved I got it
done
punk yes his motivational as anybody
ever lived he had a heart attack um had
his heart replaced
a new heart and he I don't think he's
confirmed it but he believes it's an
Asian woman I don't know if that's this
how he feels or like he's had some weird
feelings about having this other
person's heart inside of his body and he
went 100% plant-based just changed
everything changed his entire diet and
puts all these videos he thinks his
heart came from the Asian leaves his
heart came from an Asian woman I don't
think he's confirmed that because I
don't think they tell you but I think
he's he would you want to know do you
want to know yeah I kind of want to know
yeah maybe he knows now he didn't I
don't believe he knew last time I saw
him in here but you know the first time
I met him I mean he's a powerful guy you
know it's still your mother-fucking set
like it is that guy
yeah and he's just always this like
booming voice and just gigantic muscles
and he's all drive and go and then when
his heart failed and then he had to have
his heart replaced I saw him about a
year later and he had this remarkable
calm that had come over him he was just
like this different person very loving
and embracing and had all this happiness
and all this joy and all this
appreciation and now all you ain't his
plants I mean he's a and he swears by it
and light for him that's that's the way
to go no I'm not that light just saw
that right yes when you come close to
that light yeah and it's in that light
that I'm talking about his death yes if
you come close to that light when you do
and if you are fortunate enough to come
back from that light you value life
differently you can't they're there
there are no bad days for me there are
no bad days for me my biggest cry in
life came from the first day that I came
home from the hospital because I never I
never had to see that house again
like there's there was an option right
I've never seen that home again there
was an option of me never walking on
that driveway again there was an option
of me never seeing my wife and my kids
again like the biggest and I mean it
wasn't it was
like like a build up cry
it was pull up get out feet touch the
ground what the [ __ ] just came over me
boohoo yes like what the [ __ ] what just
happened and by the way a painful cry
because my back my back was [ __ ] right
so I'm crying hard and I'm in pain but
the realization of none of this has to
be you're not in control right hey Kevin
you're not in control buddy you thought
you were you move for a minute like now
I got this I'm gonna do that don't worry
about it I got it
we'll be good I'm gonna make sure it
happens as if you were in control that's
what it is it's literally that yeah at
any decision at any given time it can be
over yeah it's not until you get close
to that light that you truly respect
that I respect that there are no bad
days amen miss me with any [ __ ]
yeah I'm smiling yeah because I have no
reason to be angry because I don't have
to be here you appreciate that sunshine
cuz you've been in the pouring rain yes
man hey hey that's a [ __ ] yes so when
you talk about Ct Fletcher and you
talked about his calm you know what man
I've I've been on the other side he's
he's been yeah let's go and that's great
yeah that doesn't mean it is that he
doesn't still have that but now there's
a different energy and a different level
of relaxation that can come because I
know how fortunate I am to be taking
these steps yeah it's not just theory
like every day really truly is a gift
chase yeah and you take it for granted
real you take it for [ __ ] granite man
I'm gonna tell you not being able to
wipe my ass changed everything
you got one of the days in your house
you press the button I can't even do
that really I couldn't do that I'm
talking you you take it for granted you
take it for granted man all of this all
of this conversation is clapping as easy
Oh
hey come here all this [ __ ] here you
just you just think it's okay
you go go through go through a situation
where it's compromised how long did it
take before you can start walking again
normal or semi normal I lied in a
hospital because I didn't want them to
know that that I was having pain because
I thought today we're gonna stop me from
letting me continue to try my walks it
was like day seven in the hospital and I
had the walker and it was slow walks but
I was dragging it was upper body hmm and
and I was masking it as if I was feet
right because I didn't want to stop
trying like that was my that was my that
was my [ __ ] my my go get my drive for
anything was those that half hour forty
where I could get up and go walk because
I was just laying in the bed all day and
you know god bless me and my wife and my
kids there was there's times like if
this is the remote control and I'm in
the bed and I just want to get to the
control well I can't get to it if if you
didn't position the control down here by
my hands so I could get it this hair
throws my whole [ __ ] eye so now I
can't press the button two corners and
every second is babe can you can you
grab the control for me have do when I
was a time with my son
my son was like [ __ ] it my son just
slept in the bed with me my son he was
like I'm here dad I'm up my son didn't
want to go to school my daughter them on
school they didn't leave my side they
stayed there and middle of the night if
they heard it they heard me yeah alright
dad what you want they were up my son
doubled is nurse my daughter doubled his
nurse Nikko doubled as it you know they
they were there my brother came
and that's when the that's when the care
about what was important really changed
the [ __ ] that I thought was important
the things that you think are important
you get to looking around at a hospital
almost four walls
none of that [ __ ] that you think is
important is in there it's one of these
people none of the other [ __ ] was in
there none of it none of it was [ __ ]
in there it's also God make you feel
great that there's that much love you
know that they care about you that's
what God that's what gets you that's
what gets you through it now so those
little steps that I was taking you know
the the discomfort of not being able to
do the love and energy made me go it's
gonna be alright I'm gonna get there cuz
you definitely feel defeated a little
bit and so how long before you were
walking without a walker how stubborn
man so probably two and a half weeks to
two twenties I should have had the
walker Wow I should have had the walker
but it was I'm giving the perception
that it's that it's better than what it
is and I had the back brace on you faked
it till you make that it was definitely
I definitely I definitely was was hey
smiling what's up y'all
right good morning everybody giving this
perception you never told me you were to
visit you yeah and it's kinda see me any
certainty goes through the [ __ ] guys
already walking around yeah it's crazy
yeah I had given a perception cuz you
don't I don't want you to just to worry
yeah I got it's me yeah let me I'm going
through it I'm gonna figure it out I
don't want that worry placed on anybody
else I told you I stopped [ __ ] taking
minutes yeah so every night was it was a
horrible night that's so much better for
you though just accept that pain and
every night I did that with my knee
surgery and it's obviously a much less
painful thing but I was like I took that
[ __ ] once from one of my knee surgeries
one day and I was like this I feel so
[ __ ] stupid ass Labrador myself
that's what I said no no I was talking
to he's a slot
yeah I was by myself alone in my
apartment and I was thinking this is you
know back when I lived in New York I was
like I'm not doing this again
this is one day I would rather I'd
rather be in searing pain and have my
senses than to be stupid I felt so don't
felt dumb dommages like yeah I'm not in
escape I don't want to escape I want to
dig deep not that bad
yeah I'd rather just feel the pain I'm
not looking for that bad it's a
sensation it's a terrible sensation but
I know what it is
this is letting me know that there's a
problem and we'll fix that problem I
don't like the look that comes with
being yeah like when I see what people
look like that or I don't like that look
that's summer this year oh yeah that
when you don't know which yeah they say
yeah you you don't know what's going on
with your hands I don't like that I
don't want to look I don't want to look
like that yeah I think that's people
that are in so much pain all day just
emotionally that they just need some
sort of escape from it one thing I was
embracing it I will not knock anybody
that is dealing with any type of mental
struggle because that is something
that's so serious because nobody
understands right what that is except
that person right so I never I never
talked as if that's an easy thing I talk
that that's a thing that I don't fully
know about so you can only you can only
have some type of remorse in feeling of
understanding for people that are
battling any type of mental illness yeah
or mental health because that's just a
different it's a different monster and
different machines so whatever the
reasons to escape that are for you and
from you you know that's that's
something that's TBD to be determined
between you and whoever's trying to help
you people on the outside
we got no right we got no right if
you're not [ __ ] dealing with the same
thing you got no right to judge that
ever there's no way we can understand
what's going I'm no I can understand
what's going on in your head other than
you telling me about and me trying to
decipher it and trying to put it into
words but that's one of the more
interesting things about talking to
people it's like when you when you talk
to people and you find out how they feel
and think about things it shifts your
own ideas of what life is and and and
I'm trying to look at life through other
people's eyes and the only way you get
that is through them talking
I mean I'm dealing with it now with my
kids I got two teenagers so my daughter
you know my daughter got mad this is a
while ago she got so mad she just forget
it was like it was like a little rage I
didn't attack her for it I said there's
something that made you do that it's
bigger than just this it's not about
what we're dealing with now I said that
was double something else that I've
never seen and I said I'm gonna give you
a second take some time to yourself I
said later if you want to talk about
anything your dad is here so let's let's
talk if you want to and we got this
thing called free speaking zone and our
house free spin zone means as a parent I
can't get mad at you about what you said
I got to give you a conversation based
off of what you said and I gotta act as
if you're not my child for that moment
you cannot abuse free speaking zone
though you can't abuse it that don't
mean every time you're in trouble free
speaking zone your abuser and now you
risk free speaking zone going away I
like that idea so you gotta use it
correctly so you know my daughter came
to me and and in like the nicest voice
she was like free speaking zone and I
was like yeah I said what's up and she
just started talking to me about some
things that were bothering her and when
when we talk what I found is I can
relate to my daughter because I know for
sure that where I come from it's allowed
me to see exactly what she's seeing plus
so much more put so much more and this
was a this was a time where the hair was
an issue my daughter went through a big
hair thing you know she wanted her hair
to be a certain way and the hair
wouldn't there was no way to her hair
was going to look like what she wanted
it to so the discussion was
honey is a young black girl your hair is
not gonna do what your friends hair does
you know my daughter goes to a private
school it is white girls here you got
some Mix girls here and you know these
girls are out and they can jump in the
pool get out and their hair is a certain
way I'm like honey yours isn't gonna do
that but if you want a different look
then that means that we can work on ways
to obtain it but honey it's not gonna
happen overnight and I had to make sure
that my daughter understood how
beautiful she was I had to make sure
that my daughter understood why it's
okay for her hair to be different and be
unique and not the same I had to go into
a full father programming of making you
understand your value and my daughter
needed that but it wasn't it wasn't
something that just came out of nowhere
like dad I want to talk to you about my
hair it was an anger that she later then
came and wanted to discuss but if I
didn't have the free speaking zone
that's some [ __ ] that just would have
been in and never talked they never
talked about yeah
but I gave her something that she used
as a as a reason to say what I don't
like and don't judge me dad but this is
really making me mad well it seems like
you've developed this philosophy that
applies not just to work and not just to
success but also to family and
relationships there's a lot of carryover
in all of this it's like accepting
things for what they are but looking at
a positive way to improve them even in
terms of just communication with your
family I mean that's priority yeah
priority number one I mean that's this
it's it's so it's so dope to be able to
build what we're building because it's
not a tradition this is not we don't
have a family tradition where the rushed
right this is the first right I don't
come from mom and dad
same house kids dogs and dinner at night
at 6:00 p.m. I don't come from
right I don't know how to do that so we
are now learning that you know divorced
ex-wife new wife step kids new kid
brothers and sisters coincide with
ex-wife new wife make sure that we all
understand this is our world how do we
co-parent bumps of course figuring it
out of course kids household in our
household us build something dinners
let's make this a thing conversations no
phones let's make it a thing
movie night Taco Tuesdays game night all
this silly [ __ ] that you may look past
our memories family trips family walks
walking the dogs together all of this
[ __ ] we're building so I'm fascinated at
giving my kids stories to hold on to
when they get older remember that time
when we did said things said things said
thing where are we at that summer
remember when such and such happened and
you fell in the thing and dad had to
come get you oh my god you know what dad
you know I want to go back to you know
what we want to do we're building it so
my hope is that as I grow older I'm able
to look at a new a new era within the
heart within his heart family name
this heart legacy I'm looking at I'm
looking at generations you know I got
two sons I got two sons man that's a
that's an unbelievable thing because
this name goes I got a daughter that's
my oldest I'm about to have another
daughter like now it's like [ __ ] have
you really it's bigger than you it's
it's about this and it's about what they
have but it's about what they remember
I'm doing my part in life to go back to
what we talked about earlier by making
this generation better than what I was
I'm giving you the [ __ ] tools guys
you don't got to do what I do you don't
got to be what I am but I'm giving you
the tools to at least want to aspire to
be is there a struggle to find time like
to manage the time between work and
family relationships now after that
accident no not that [ __ ] accident
accident was the the the best i opening
experience ever you know I mean it's I
was married to my career dating my
family mmm
right like I'm right I'm all about this
work and all about this hustle granted
there's nothing wrong with that it's a
good thing but after a certain point you
got to prioritize accordingly when you
know when you get to a certain point
where the decisions that can be made are
a little more controlled and you have
the ability to maneuver differently
because of the success that you've
obtained make those adjustments I didn't
make those adjustments I was still
hustle hustle hustle cranek great dad
I'm we're doing stuff I'm home I'm
getting back home but my in and outs
three days I'm out two days three days
I'm out I gotta go from the movie y'all
come down for the weekends all right I
see you guys will eat dinner we'll do
stuff and it's great crammed it all in
all right y'all got to go I'm working
and it's not bad but now all right I'm
from a movie after I'm done filming a
movie well I got I need to take 30 days
off I need to take 40 days off that's
just with me in the fam now a you go
tour it was just bough year and a half
we out four days out the [ __ ] week
I'm out year and a half I got to get it
well now let's go a month and a half a
stop for three weeks
I'm with the fam so I still have my
three days a week that I was here but
then I'm gonna stop for three weeks this
is dedicated to phantom don't nobody do
anything with me or talk to me I'm
I'm home now my office I was in that
office when we [ __ ] open office
opening nine I'm there eight you know
there's a chance that I may be in that
office till [ __ ] six now yo no matter
what guys that day in the office has to
end it like three I gotta be home for
dinner I got dinner with the fam my
priorities have changed but it brings me
back to the decisions that you are now
able to make based off of life's
circumstances life's lessons so because
of all the [ __ ] that I went through
because of the things that I now got to
see because of that hospital room in
those four walls and me seeing my family
and what that love did for me and to me
well I'll be damned if I [ __ ] look
past that I'll be damned if I not do
what I'm supposed to do and give that
the same amount of attention in return
cuz my eyes got open [ __ ] is that why
that happened what are you saying to me
was I supposed to what
okay I'm gonna assume I'm gonna assume
and I'm gonna look at the signs that are
clearly being given I'm gonna try my
best to do my part I'm gonna try my best
to grow so my time now is it's so
valuable but the priority within my time
I'm making sure that the people that I
love and that love me have some time
when it's all said and done I want to
know that I made those adjustments I
want to know that I did my part you
achieved that balance absolutely yeah
but it was learned yeah it was learned
now this is information yes it's [ __ ]
information and and there's one side of
information that I had which was go get
it I'm out I'm out I got to go get it I
got time to [ __ ] stay in here man
it's [ __ ] to do which I still do do I
don't want to make seem like that isn't
in me but there's a balance
there's now a balance that's the
trickiest [ __ ] in life it's it yeah it's
to find that balance find a bounds not
just be a [ __ ] savage out there
grinding and attacking all day but to
have that balance and appreciate
especially appreciate family right it's
it's it's something that I that I've had
to learn and that I'm still learning
it's not something that I'm knocked out
the park completely yet because it's a
growing [ __ ] living yeah you just you
gotta just keep being a sponge and being
willing to [ __ ] grow tell me about
this audible doing audible is an amazing
partner of mine now my first book I
can't make this up life lessons was a
New York Times number-one bestseller and
I got bit I got bit by the bug Wow as an
author I wanted to write a book I did it
look at the success that it had the
opportunity came up for me to voice that
book on audible and the audible success
was just as good if not greater than my
hardcover and people loved the fact that
the stories were real but hearing my
voice and hearing me be personable while
being real was a bonus from other things
and they've ever had the privilege of
listening to so I said I want to do
another one man but I'm big on this
motivation self-help inspiration thing
I'm I'm really big on trying to do my
part so as I was telling you earlier I
said in my life man I got so so many
stories of all of my twists and turns
and right moves and wrong moves and
decision making that enhanced those
moves or that devalue them and made them
incorrect ultimately if I were to give
information it's just to open up people
eyes is to open up your eyes to to the
reality of you competing with you
I want people to understand that we lose
because we are ok with ignoring our
faults right it's not until you can
accept your faults your [ __ ] that
you can grow and do better we point the
finger a lot by we myself included I'm
an example of it yo I didn't do that
because nobody told me I didn't get up I
didn't hear the alarm why don't you call
me and get me up yeah I didn't know he
was gonna go eat didn't want to tell me
he's gonna go eat I woulda came to eat
but if y'all you tell me I know he had a
test today why don't you tell me how to
test day I didn't study because anybody
reach out and tell me there's so many
things that we place the blame on others
for that are truly our responsibility
and it becomes a habit it's a force of
habit so it's not at you break that
habit that you can do bigger and better
[ __ ] so this audible original of mine
called the decision is about making you
look at [ __ ] differently making you
realize the tone of today and making you
understand how much you're a part of it
I got a big thing on social media near
where I'm like social media is mind [ __ ]
people and to people now thinking that
it's what the world thinks social media
has mine [ __ ] people into thinking that
the comments below a post are what the
world must be feeling and thinking about
you the insecurity levels have raised to
an all-time high because my belief is
now I posted something people are saying
these things underneath I don't want to
go outside because this is how they feel
mmm so I've now put this [ __ ] in my head
that as soon as I walk outside if you
look at me you talk about my posts ain't
you what folks [ __ ] your tongue mouth
right you stop my post didn't you that's
why you looking at me like that
I don't what do you what we now think
that this is the way of the world right
and we're so engulfed into it that the
negative is so loud that you don't even
see the putz
- even if it's overwhelmingly positive
need a few negative you don't see it you
concentrate on those negative you you
don't see it yeah there was a black
billionaire that paid off student loans
it was a story for about a day and a
half another story popped up of reality
thar suck somebody dick in the bathroom
it went on for three weeks it was
[ __ ] crazy news
it's breaking [ __ ] news what that's
all over the place the reason why is
because we spread the negative as people
we've fallen in love with bad
information and bad conversation no
we're intrigued by it what's a natural
human instinct because those are the
things that can kill you like know the
days when we were you know living in
small villages worried about animals
attacking us you had to be always
worried about negative negative is the
thing you had to concentrate on cuz that
could take your life positive was
something that's great
that's good and all but really got to
concentrate on negative and
unfortunately that human instinct is
carried over into this time where we
don't really have the same fear of
danger that we had before for the most
part but we still concentrate on these
negative things we still concentrate on
negative comments negative stories these
negative things carry more weight
because we have a natural inclination to
keep an eye out for danger it's a it's
like our human reward system's been
hijacked it's been hijacked by social
media this new thing that we're not
prepared for reading anonymous written
things that are negative and it [ __ ]
and you know there's a book called the
coddling of the American mind by
Jonathan hate and he wrote about this
with children about how many especially
girls so many girls are experiencing
super high levels of self-harm suicide
and depression all because of social
media because they're writing things and
their friends are commenting on them and
people are anonymously saying you stupid
fat [ __ ] who [ __ ] with their head in a
way that other generations before didn't
have to deal with before social media
there was nothing that could affect them
in this way and and you know stuff
because there's gifts and there's curses
to it of course like there's a there's
an amazing benefit behind it and of
course now we're seeing the you know the
bad within it so what I encourage any a
everybody to do is just understand who
you are truly understand who you are
learn yourself yeah
learn yourself learn your pros and cons
get your flaws get them out the way but
with you not nobody else nobody this is
a you and you thing of the [ __ ] that you
know you need to work on I'm telling you
people when you really look yourself in
a mirror and you start to pick yourself
apart by yourself yeah there's only room
for improvement
it's easy to ignore your [ __ ]
also other people can't tell you things
you don't already know [ __ ] yeah you're
a thousand percent right yeah you're a
thousand percent right and it's that's
what this is my my audio book is not a
live like me tutorial it's not a do what
I did tutorial it's I would never do
that because I don't have all the
answers all I have is stories and
information that you can now be privy to
that can allow you to make different
[ __ ] turns on his road of life what
what was the motivation to do this it
was a one thing or was there it was it
was it a build up me being me being one
of the only black guys in our
entertainment space because there's a
handful of us that get to look behind a
curtain
there's a curtain there's another room
and there's a curtain and in that room
is some [ __ ] you like goddamn I didn't
know y'all was [ __ ] doing this back
here I don't know I was getting this
type of money back y'all been doing this
how long this is how it happens there's
a there's a room that you get in and the
information and understanding that comes
in it the end it's it's unreal the stuff
that you start to discover but it's a
discovery it's a discovery
you got to stumble upon this treasure of
information and discovery and if you
don't maybe you're in the right
environment you hear some stuff you can
ask some question
but nine times out of ten it's not
offered it's a search and fine and when
I was constantly in those situations and
I find myself saying so how but why well
then what did you do right
damn after that didn't what what the
[ __ ] did you what how did that even work
I was in a room with Jeff Bezos and
Robert Kraft this was the the Patriots
have won a Super Bowl and we're we're in
like the this little private room after
and Tom Brady is like giving a speech
thinking Robert for all Robert thinks
time and I whip my wife and a friend and
Jeff Bezos walks in my friend go to go
Jeff Bezos oh [ __ ] Oh save a sudden
assessment [ __ ] I would love to pick his
brain that's an interesting individual
no I'm do that what you mean don't do
that don't do the friend
why are we talking about why you don't
do that cuz the roomful of people don't
look like the dude is thirsty thirsty
for what for [ __ ] information dick
face we aren't alike look who got into
like little [ __ ] back for what
[ __ ] information I want to [ __ ] and
say hey I want to see my face I want to
ask him some questions
henkle see this man no more I don't know
him we're not on a phone number the
phone number basis i'ma say what's up to
him
I got do you I'm just saying and this
farmers just chill it's relaxed and that
[ __ ] start to click to me that's the
problem
everybody's too cool everybody's too
[ __ ] cool right everybody wants you
to think that they know you don't know
you don't know [ __ ]
we don't know [ __ ] there's one Jeff
Bezos this [ __ ] one he's right almost
Chilean ear hey Jeff come here man first
of all explain two trillion to me what
is that how many zero what is that first
of all do you know excited he must be to
talk to you two who knows imma [ __ ]
find out [ __ ] flatten it out you know
I did joke what
hey man happy right back babe come on
took my wife with me age
I'm Kevin Hart how you doing man hey
Kevin how are you justice my wifey Nico
hey hey man I admire you I don't [ __ ]
know anything about that world and death
but I admire you I admire you for being
a guy that [ __ ] created and
accomplished some [ __ ] that is a
phenomenon I want to shake your hand I
would love to talk one day Kenneth amen
good meeting you quite sure we'll bump
past one day hey if we do it don't you
gonna remember this I just want to tell
you I admire you I don't need [ __ ] I'm
not asking for anything but what I did I
set myself up for another conversation
for when I got the opportunity you're
talking here but I'm gonna come over man
I admire you I wanna [ __ ] ask you a
bunch of questions about this Amazon
[ __ ] and that's why you came up with it
I don't think this is the time or place
but I want you to see my face have you
ever seen the photo of him sitting at
his desk and there's a banner behind
them a plastic nylon like hanging banner
it says amazon.com it's in like the
1990s when people like what the [ __ ] you
doing selling books on the internet and
this is a shitty looking Ikea desk look
at this look at him this is him here in
marker yeah we sprayed some great paint
look at shitty look at that shitty
[ __ ] desk that dorky looking dude
look at the cords yeah now he's off buff
and jacked and [ __ ] Jesus now he's a
savage that's basically conquering the
business world richest man Wow
richest man publicly I think there's a
bunch of them oh yeah just got some [ __ ]
- don't think just shut up they don't
want to say anything
yeah either way I was in a room with
that man yeah I didn't
there wasn't a level of cool that I had
that that would keep me from just going
in saying hello or asking a question for
that matter right and and it's being in
those spaces that intrigue the thought I
was like dude this is what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna do my part I'm gonna do my
part and say it I'm gonna say hey when
it comes to producing and production
here's what I've done here's the walls
that I've hit and here
where's really hurt me but here's what I
learned and here's why I do it this way
my ambition is fueled from possibility
I'm giving you all this [ __ ] I'm giving
you all the [ __ ] when I'm doing my dying
take you with me yeah I'm gonna keep it
in the coffin with me I'm do let me do
it
yeah I'm a [ __ ] give it well also the
possibility that some young kid could
listen to this audio thing listen do you
talk about these things and then one day
succeed and run into you the same way
you ran into Jeff Bezos yeah running
you're Kevin Hart oh my god I gotta tell
you I got where I am because I listened
I listened to you talk about your life
I listen you talk about your fuck-ups
and that you made me feel like you're
human like I thought you were just Kevin
Hart like when people see you you're
Kevin Hart you're walking the red carpet
you know you're you're in Jumanji you're
all over the place [ __ ] comedy
specials for 50,000 people in arenas and
[ __ ]
people don't know that you're a human
you don't seem like a human because
you're not like a human that they know
but when you talk and you talk about
your life and some kid might just get a
spark off of them blow that spark make
that Ember flame up and take over and
next thing you know you're running into
that person it's a mother Superbowl
party I can't even do I can't even tell
you that's the I mean that's that's what
it's about
it's about your offering fuel that's
that that's as strong as anything else
yeah that's gonna it's gonna impact some
people you know there's gonna be people
that don't have room for it right
they're all closed up it said that it
you know this like a cup there's no room
in their cup they're full of their own
[ __ ] he's not gonna get in there who
there's other people they're gonna have
a spot for you they're gonna spot and
you're gonna you're gonna make that
engine better you're gonna make the
whole engine of their life better
there's there's things that I think
about all the time when I'm working out
or when I'm tired or I think about
inspirational things that people have
said and they they get me through this
shift shifts my mind steals me up makes
me makes me think about things in a
different way and I can accomplish more
because of those thoughts I can
accomplish more because of that energy
that some
and you did that to me man you did that
to me the last time we had a
conversation I remember leaving our
conversation going that motherfucker's
motivational and I got a lot of text
messages from a lot of friends a lot of
people that was a great one but it was
the the there was a shift like when when
when someone is really getting a stirred
in their life and you around them
there's a shift in your own life and
this this it's a tangible thing it's
like if you could see it on a meter you
know it's almost like your meter goes up
and you feel it but you don't you don't
quantify you know it's not something you
put on a scale it's not something you'd
see on a meter but it's real and you got
to believe it's real and know it's real
and when you're doing this when you're
putting out this audio book and even
these conversations that you put out
when you people know what you've
accomplished and you put these
conversations out it resonates man it's
so valuable did you did you see did you
watch - Jordan duck no I didn't you know
my satellites - I know everybody's that
you have I know I have - you have to
watch the time listen you because he's
he's an alien he's one of us he's one of
he's one of those aliens the other
aliens identify with and for people
listening me when I say aliens you know
it's a metaphor people that doesn't mean
a bit [ __ ] embracing aliens here oh I
get so much [ __ ] for everything it's a
metaphor okay but he he's different
he's [ __ ] different and what this
shows you is how different MJ was that
man was a [ __ ] winner he was a winner
and and that's that's it
like that's it MJ one there was no there
is no other conversation when you watch
this doc and you watch how he approached
his days and why he approached it and
the things that he did and his reason
for doing them and ultimately what he
wanted and what his priority and with
his goal
were you go [ __ ] he did it we know why
he did it it's not a coincidence that
he's a champion it's destiny he there
was no other option
it was champion or bus there was no 600
vp's all-star and the defense played
here and you know most likable player in
the league and most remarkable no no if
it's not a champion attached to my name
with several [ __ ] trophies attacked
there is no other conversations and you
[ __ ] around me if you do not
understand why I am the way I am then
this is not the place for you do your
job I've never heard Michael Jordan talk
the way the documentary showed him talk
do your [ __ ] job when I pass you the
ball hit the [ __ ] shot that person
now has to get better hmm
because I'm so nervous that it might
pass me the ball and I miss this [ __ ]
shot I'm never going to get a shot again
yeah do your [ __ ] job when Mike is
talking to you like that I thought we
was just playing basketball I thought I
was out here having a good time oh wait
this is my job this is my profession I'm
supposed to do this this and this if I
don't do this I'm failing at my job you
see these players today and you see the
way that they are I promise you man rest
in peace Kobe Bryant every bit of the
same they give my guy
LJ flak and [ __ ] I promise you LeBron
James is nothing short of that I promise
you these people that are winning
[ __ ] win because there is no other
option you have to watch this doc and
Joe you got to text me after okay text
me after and just go holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] man I get it keV
and the fuel that you're talking about
and that meter I promise you your meter
[ __ ] yeah I got it after the day I got
up [ __ ] over here was in the dock let me
think of what the next thing is it
instantly yeah instantly fuel fuel
instant fuel last time I felt that was
the Tison documentary I'm strong it was
strong dude there's a the time when he's
talking about walking into the ring that
as he steps in the ring all the
nervousness all the things that going
through says and that is his confidence
bills as it gets towards the ring any
steps through the ropes I'm a god what
he says holy [ __ ] that's that's that's
until second man to me yeah that's the
dough sekiz man to me it's crazy he's
hurting again that's that is the dough
sekiz man to me though most interesting
man in America that Mike Tyson yeah is
that there are so many different levels
and and pieces of death yeah
to Mike Tyson in his story one of the I
mean it's one of the strongest docs
I've ever seen well he's he's one of
those guys one of those super winners
that just I mean when he was young I
mean everyone knows the story but if you
don't
he was basically had no love in his life
until he met custom auto and custom auto
became a father figure but also custom
auto was a hypnotist and a psychologist
in a lot of ways and a fantastic boxing
coach as well and took this young kid
and showed him that you're gonna get
love from accomplishment and you're
gonna conquer and you're gonna become
the greatest heavyweight boxer of all
time and through his tutelage up until
the moment that he died Mike Tyson was
just a just a phenom a thing that we had
never seen before he was the pit bull
with no leash that that respected one
person yes and anybody else at any given
time feared to [ __ ]
out of his pit bull because nobody else
knew hey man yeah who's what is hey yeah
somebody gotta get this hey whoa what
yeah what is this with today if I see
Mike this stood out there's a little
nervousness for no reason for sure it's
not like he's coming in with this thing
like I'm killing it right now but this
is gentle he's a most loving man in the
world you talk to him he's all spoken
but there's still a little thing like
this Michael hit me my friend Kevin Lee
said it best Kevin Lee fights for the
UFC he said what he said next time he
goes he goes that's a lion oh my god you
know this fight man I just you know wish
him the best I know he's back there's
writing and stuff you know I just want
him to be safe and in and healthy and
his time but you know that's the man I
don't ever count out but goddamn seeing
him just put up those little displays of
terrifying fighters it's what it's
verified heat-seeking missiles coming
from his shoulders well not only that he
wasn't doing anything like a year ago
when I had him in here for the podcast
he said he didn't want to stoke his ego
he didn't want to work out he goes
because if I work out my ego fires up
there is look at this look at this look
at this [ __ ] here but you know that
that's that's interesting but that's
just shadowboxing who was crazy is he's
training with Rafael Cordeiro who's one
of the best MMA trainers one of the best
striking trainers in the world he came
from a legendary camp out of Brazil
Curitiba Brazil called shoot the box
it's like the legendary team of
marauders from Brazil they were like the
the golden glory days of pride pride was
you know a competitor to the UFC was
defined in a lot of ways the glory days
are defined by this one team from Brazil
that ha Falco Dara was a part of and
then that guy training Mike Tyson now
and he's been super successful training
mixed martial arts fighters too but I
found it very interesting that Mike
chose to train with that guy and to see
the way they're going at it mean
he's not boxing he's trying to destroy
mothers listen you you I respect the
trainer I respect the trainer for
standing in that in the way of that [ __ ]
like that's yes one must one one
accidental oops
missiles no listen you gotta just you
gotta just bow down yeah and and you
know what man that's we're still in the
presence of greatness and as people I
don't I don't think we should ever
forget that
well what's crazy is he's 53 years old
he's doing this and he's only been doing
this again for like less than a year so
it's only been like four or five months
that he's really been training hard and
everything's just coming back it's I
mean I wonder I wonder what it is I
wonder if it just was bored I mean I
really wanted this is this is the crazy
[ __ ] Jesus Christ Jesus Christ if you
saw that guy if you saw that guy
training he was a 22 year old kid you
like man this [ __ ] is gonna be
something because he's just got an
intensity that you rarely see from any
fighter there's a fury that burns inside
of him that you you can't manufacture
that you either have that or you don't
and he found a way to reach reignite it
I was a school you beat me to it yeah
you beat me to it but this isn't that
what isn't that what we we hope for or
you know yes we hope that we get you
know I think at that age 50 that's it
that's a very pivotal pivotal pivotal
how do you say that that's pivotal yeah
all right that's a very pivotal word
pivot word pivotal point in your life
because you know from when you're born
to 50 you're that's okay um all my years
fun are out the way my my craziness my
growth my maturity and now I'm supposed
to start to be a little complacent and
you know I'm now at that at that hill
where I'm looking on the other side of
life like now it's time to go on another
side and we want
other side you know even if you're still
on a high about living in about career
and everything you're on the other side
it's it's it's a different thing we on
the other side I made it here now how
many more years it's a blessing to get
more time after this because I've made
it to the top and now you know on this
other side is it relaxing is it not am i
comfortable am I am i a little depressed
that I'm getting old
am I not what whatever those emotions
and feelings are they're real and and a
lot of people experience it have them so
to find something else to make you go
I'm ready again Will Smith did it Will
Smith kicked in yeah
Will Smith something clicked something
clicked on Will Smith for years Will
Smith was it around and will to talk to
you we'll talk to you will to tell you
but something clicked and he said at
this age at 50 I'm gonna go get it again
i'ma go after it again because I can
like it's something in there that Will
Smith realizes that he has and at any
given moment I can and that's what will
Smith shoulders well Smith wasn't on
social media Will Smith it wasn't in
this you know and the in the Generation
X you know he wasn't in our face he
wasn't up in up in the [ __ ] vlogs and
[ __ ] in YouTube on a day-to-day he
didn't have more movies coming out it
was very far fueling in between and then
he said I'll do it when the [ __ ] I want
and he turned it on 37 million followers
40 something million followers whatever
vlogs on YouTube I'm on snapchat I'm on
at all Twitter
tick-tock I'm gonna show you how to do
it I got my own team we showed you guys
a new way to do this [ __ ] I'm producing
it different than it was I'm back to
doing movies here's my new movies we're
using a new technology Gemini man young
me old me he's [ __ ] doing what he
wants because he said he can everybody
doesn't have that everybody can't do
this
y'all not people to try yeah but they
don't do that you don't go from being
number one and saying I'm not gonna do
it and I had some failures or whatever
in here and it fall up [ __ ] I'm ready
to be number one again that's some of
our favorite stories door someone who
comes back like Dave Chappelle is a
perfect example of that I can do what
the [ __ ] I want
not only that Dave did it in the
legendary way they are from all this
money to do this Comedy Central show in
a different way they want him to change
it and tone it down they want to make it
more suitable for advertisers too many
voices and he's like you know what I'm
just gonna go to Africa I'm out he just
went to Africa I'm out just took off and
then came back and said I quit and then
stopped doing stand-up he was doing song
if you know he was doing stand-up in a
park yeah in Seattle you'd show up with
a [ __ ] box and just do it
plug a microphone into it and just start
doing standing but people would gather
round like what the [ __ ] is happening
here no he didn't want any money he
would just show up it shows if you
wanted to do a show he would show up at
a comedy club no money just show up do a
show after the show is over I ready
laughs it's a great Dave Chappelle story
I'm in Seattle I think I was in Seattle
sold out like some Arena [ __ ] thing
I'm doing a Seattle and we had two shows
same night we do about 30,000 people
right [ __ ] great day Seattle I get
word that Dave Chappelle is in Seattle
and Dave Chappelle randomly put up a
theater show he's performing tonight
yeah he's performing tonight called Dave
David you [ __ ] in Seattle yeah
wouldn't you book a show here I would
have [ __ ] came dude I'm here I'm at
the theater I didn't even know me what
you meet Dave I'm at the [ __ ] Arena
what I I'm gonna see if I can get down
there to you all right man yeah I just
put them up what time you think you
won't get here I don't know after my
show I'll push the time back me
Dave what push the time back what did
you put on set I don't know Matt tell
him I'll do it and I show up man I just
call him tell him I'm gonna push you
back man I get to the [ __ ] theater I
rush after our show dave has a a trailer
and there's like a little motor thing on
the back of the trailer it's like a
little bus [ __ ] motor trend like bus
and then there's like little the things
that you pull [ __ ] in attached to it I
said hey what are you doing here he's I
don't know my we've been doing
cross-country taking out bikes my ride
cross-country so I'll just when I need
money I just booked a show so different
and he sold him but the freedom yeah
dave has a level of freedom and Chris
Rock talked about it man you know no
one's like him his level of freedom I
put myself in his place you know I got
the the the corporate relationships and
the CEO head and the companies so you
know I can't do certain things because
the consequences aren't just for me
it's for the people that are underneath
this umbrella if something were to
happen it's I have to be I have to be
responsible I have to I have to
understand that it's not just about me
right and I'm envious and jealous of
Dave's ability to go and be free as a
comic in the times where we desperately
need to be yes
with desperately need to be and Dave can
be and I bow down to him I called it I
don't give a [ __ ] about these numbers
anything I got Dave in my opinion you're
the goat in my opinion your last special
has allowed you to surpass the Richard
Pryor in my opinion Dave Chappelle I got
to witness do groundbreaking
controversal movement as a comedian and
the times where comedy was being frowned
upon comedians were being held
accountable for doing what we thought we
would never be ridiculed for right the
one person that stood on a pedestal that
got the attention that no others can get
outside of myself a rock a Seinfeld he
said in the time where the [ __ ] fire
is the hottest I'm going to do what
nobody else will you got a [ __ ]
applaud and he stood up for coming he
stood up for comedy whether you want to
see that or not right he did that yes he
did it when there's the most pressure
when it was the most [ __ ] pressure and
when the times of we could cancer you by
the way which is the stupidest [ __ ] that
I've ever [ __ ] witnessed in my 40
years of life the whole idea of I can
kill you today with it with the goddamn
cooking oh by not getting your life by
the way this is a real feeling that
people have yes I'm in control of your
life if I want your life to stop and be
over I'll counsel you yeah and that
means you can't live no more this is how
ridiculous it is think about the meaning
of counsel culture so you're saying that
my life is over I can no longer survivor
or provide for myself canceled
I don't know figured out your cancel
Dave Chappelle said [ __ ] all that do
what you wanna do I'm gonna do me that
is epic that is groundbreaking that is
goat-like behavior so I bow down to mr.
Chappelle he's very important he's one
of the most important figures in the
history of comedy because the fact that
he's willing to do this when the
scrutiny is the highest you know and and
also just his his just his story the
back the way he did it the way he walked
away for 10 years and then came back and
immediately went right to the top you
know my that is my
I as my brother from another mother I
love love him Chris Rock Miyagi one more
man Chris Rock white a Comedy Cellar I
call Chris hey Chris come down to the
cellar man I'm working some jokes
tonight I'll see what you think
iCup how come now Chris comes down say
yeah I'm get up to I got some [ __ ] I'm
working on so told you think bet I go on
stage Chris Rock sits in the back of the
cellar get off stage Chris not funny
[ __ ] keV though like right got some
stuff got some notes he's like I'm about
to go aren't done I'm sitting watching
Chris goes up Chris got some funny [ __ ]
[ __ ] Chris funny I like it man Chris
have a nice conversation go upstairs we
about to eat
Dave comes in what update what you doing
I was gonna go up oh [ __ ] man Chris went
up we will come down watching alright
Dave goes on stage Dave does about an
hour there's a moment where Dave is
probably at about 40 45 minutes in I
mean Chris both look at each other and
at the same time when I was saying the
word balled up the material that we just
worked we we [ __ ] without saying it
what I was saying it I ripped the page
that I had in my little book and Chris
just balled up his little [ __ ] thing
and we were like he's unbelievable we
came in crafted we got some [ __ ] that we
wanted the [ __ ] work on Dave just one
of there and talked it's like he's
living like a legend
you know man like if you if you wanted
to have a legend of a comedian you talk
about a guy who created the greatest
sketch show of all time
I mean it only went for two seasons but
when you talk about like sketches like
Clayton Bigsby when you talk about the
Rick James [ __ ] these are so classic
they're unstoppable and then he goes
away he goes away like a [ __ ]
Mountain Man he vanishes he's in a farm
in Ohio you hear where is he
he's on a farm he got a [ __ ] farm
just on a farm in Ohio what is he doing
comedy sometimes randomly just shows up
Santa's barn does this for 10 years
I was in Denver right and this is before
his comeback I was in Denver and I'm
doing stand-up and I get offstage and I
open the green room and
beeps there I go Dave what are you doing
and he goes oh hey Joe I just decided to
fly into Denver I go you don't have a
show scheduled nothing goes nah man I
heard you were here outside a fly and I
go do you want to go up it goes oh
should I go [ __ ] yeah hold on a second
I've run back people are leaving people
get another go come back come back tell
everybody to come back I go Dave
Chappelle's here like what they all come
back sit down and he does 40 minutes
it destroys I love the the best part of
that story is you want to go up shut up
Dave Dave you just took a flight to
Denver yeah baby why not I guess so then
he takes me out we go out on the town to
all these [ __ ] spots I didn't even
know existed in Denver he knows where
all these after-hours place yeah you go
behind an alley you knock on a door they
open it up yeah everything's
velvet-lined yeah small private bar he's
he's he is one he's one of one one of
one of one one of one this is what the
[ __ ] is should be like you see this is
this is us embracing this is us
embracing we're embracing someone yes
embracing that there's nothing wrong
with that world is important there's
nothing wrong there's nothing wrong with
embracing someone is doing [ __ ] what
you can deem is great [ __ ] you're
supposed to you suppose to you have to
it's part of the thing you have to also
sing praise shower preys on people that
are doing it the right way yeah no one's
ever done it better than Dave he's doing
it the right way no and even like I said
even the legendary Stuart's like oh he's
like a character in a book a mountain
man he's like a mountain man it goes off
to a farm outside of Dayton Ohio
who the [ __ ] does that away it tells me
keV you got to come down to the farm
Dave I don't what I don't know what hey
I don't want it what do you want me to
do down there Dave
what do you want me to do you gotta come
down man it's a good time we're gonna
have a good time man it's a barn fires
music Dave it's a farm you got to
promise me all right I'm coming Dave I
[ __ ] I like literally I I
can only hope to be remotely close to
his creative as he is at that point in
my career and finest jello-like he's in
an amazing jello right now he knows who
he is right and in that compromise and
no one can tell him any different he is
who he is I mean he just he's
unapologetically himself and he gets it
as part of his brilliance is not just
being in a brilliant observer and a
brilliant orator and a describer of life
but also and being who he is perfectly
like he doesn't have any conflict in
being who he is
mm-hmm he knows who knows how do you do
it he knows how to do it right and he's
okay with not having and when he walks
onstage man he strolls on that stage
like he belongs there he's okay yeah I'm
having let me go [ __ ] you I you know any
more feet I've met Eddie Murphy man I
don't know him very well but I knew his
brother Charlie very well that's Eddie
we had a dinner one night and it was
Eddie Murphy Dave Chappelle me Chris
Rock Chris Tucker holy [ __ ] and Dwayne
Wade Gabrielle Union and usher head came
Wow right so where we're at this dinner
and me and Chris was like yo we should
get let's just put a dinner together
where we all just come out because me
and Chris loved to [ __ ] just hear
Eddie go like Eddie is pound for pound
the funniest person you can ever be
around like effortlessly not trying just
in story this dinner goes down to
history is the funny is the funniest
night of my life and conversation and
you got to see comics be in all of one
another
you got to see us appreciate each other
like like everybody talked to Nick this
wasn't a 1-up story each other this was
a conversation but you saw the you saw
why
the goats were the goats yes you saw why
the goats where the goats you clearly
saw that I was young in class and I'm
the the guy that's coming up in the rear
and I'm Mike I'm happy to be there might
be a static man there I'm [ __ ]
smiling yeah sure there's a picture of
it I'm smiling ear-to-ear
damn Jamie skills I'm smiling ear to
[ __ ] ear and I remember there was a
moment where we were talking and Eddie
would say something and then Christic
like come on man you know damn well at
the end am i doing that and then you'll
[ __ ] hear Dave shut up damn it Chris
which it rocked and then I'm just
dealing quiet I'm just [ __ ] quiet Wow
and then I would have more table tuning
but literally you saw why the goats word
it goes wow
I'm telling you one of the most epic
dinners I had this picture framed in my
house that's amazing amazing framed in
my [ __ ] house god I hope that he
comes back I know he's been talking
about he's been talking about it did you
see that one thing they did there was
some sort of an awards show where he
came up and talked on the podium and he
was doing material and he was talking
about them taken away Bill Cosby's
degrees no you never seen it no Jaime
find it find it recent his recent it's
like within the last couple of years bro
his timing isn't he he would just get up
there right now and murder well you saw
it you saw it also in his SNL sketch he
did the one SNL sketch where he did the
it was like the the holiday the holiday
family and it was like the black family
yeah and his daughter brought the white
guy home and it was the black family's
reaction to it cuz he was staying there
over the weekend so Eddie was dead but
she saw his time and it was time I was
there man he's still [ __ ] Eddie
Murphy yeah we'll play this and we'll
wrap this up we'll just ended on this
your [ __ ] is available on audible yes
sir now yes right now
right now you're a brilliant person I
really appreciate you I'm angry [ __ ] you
being here I [ __ ] with you Joe I'm
serious man I I want to say this I
couldn't be happier for you and for all
of
your listeners all of your supporters I
want to thank y'all for staying with
this man and Ryan with this man through
the years because you know to build
something and have that something means
something that's valuable
dude you serve a very strong purpose in
today's time I'm a fan and I'm happy to
call myself a friend [ __ ] what you'd
appreciate I mean that research I mean
Eddie Murphy ladies and gentlemen did
you make bill give his back no cuz I
know it was a big outcry from people it
was trying to get bill to give his
trophies back you know you anyone should
give you trophies
Choki back - he should do one show we
just come out and just talk crazy now I
would like to talk to some of the people
who feel that I should give back my
strawberries
oh it's only a piece of it huh Mark
Twain speech Wow well if we play more
they probably pull it down anyway that's
good enough oh my god it was brilliant
strong thank you so much thank you
brother bye everybody
[Music]